well I'm joined Now by Anthony Wier
Anthony good to see you you as well nice
to have you back in town well it's been
a long time uh I actually worked up the
last time I interviewed you 2011 right
before a lot of stuff happened in your
life at the time you were doing well in
the polling to be the mayor of New York
City uh you were a very Dynamic pretty
successful Congressman popular um and I
interviewed you in a debate with Donald
Trump where the two of you went at each
other and it cated with you saying to
him that you had more chance of becoming
president than he
did yeah that's right it was a while ago
that was bad I think you once my time
had a successful show on CNN look how
much can
change good thing um interesting though
how things have played out since then
for for Donald Trump who obviously has
now been president do you think he can
be president
again well it doesn't seem that way I
mean we just had this race this exact
same race and so one thing one
determining fact factor in a race is how
it's g in the past Biden beat him pretty
easily just three years ago so I don't
really think that you should expect that
much it's hard to see how how Donald
Trump improved his chances n being under
indictment by the American people in 91
instances it doesn't seem that way and
it doesn't seem frankly that even his
own party is that enthusiastic about him
returning so I think at the end of the
day most Democrats don't want Biden to
run again they think he's too old most
Republicans don't want Trump to R to run
against so that's one thing they have in
common they're both old they're both
unpopular with their parties they're
going to be the nominees and I I see
just like look if you look at it every
time that that that Donald Trump has run
2016 lost the popular vote 2018 his
party got shellacked 2020 he lost by 7
million votes 2022 in the midterms where
Republicans should have done amazingly
they got squashed so the party of Donald
Trump is not a successful party and I
see no reason it'll change this year
let's talk about you I saw an interview
you did that's it we're done talking
about the election no no I'm going to
come back to the elction
I'm interested in in your story I'm not
running I think that would be a relief
to a lot of people not your supporters
of which I'm sure you have have a lot of
support still but let me ask you
about I guess Scandal I saw you say in
an interview recently where you said
very hard to move on from a sex scandal
if your name's weer which made me laugh
right but it's true right your headline
created itself really with your name
throughout that process what has it been
like for you just getting your life back
on
track well I I look I'm I'm healthier
I'm in recovery I serve time in prison I
uh I'm on the radio now so I'm not in in
public life but I'm having my say uh
it's kind of I'm actually surprised
you're not doing more more in
introduction to the subject to your to
your listeners and viewers because it's
been a while now so it's kind of receded
a good deal well when people ask you
well let you do it when people ask you
what you did what do you say I said I
had a scandal I I had a a scandal where
I was texting and texting dozens and
dozens of people and and and got me in
trouble cost me my career cost me my
wife cost me my family cost me a lot of
things cost me my Liberty um but I also
say I'm exactly where I'm supposed to be
right now that I I believe that these
things happen I think you some people
need to hit a lower bottom than other
people uh but I I say that I have um I
don't have a lot of regrets in that I
kind of believe that I'm where I'm
supposed to be right now what was the
lowest
moment so the lowest moment was look I
mean the the lowest moment was when I gu
it's hard to say it's a good question I
haven't asked that I guess the lowest
moment was when you know my my my son
someone sold a picture to the newspapers
of me with my son which was obviously
very difficult for me to see and and you
know but I you were in bed with him and
you were also sexing somebody well I
wasn't sexing anyone it was yeah the
without going into the detail which
aren't really that important what's
important is that he was this someone
sold a picture with him in it and you
know at the time I was spending frankly
a lot of time with as I always did with
my son he was in the picture but the the
the the the harm that I I did so many
people it was proba frankly long before
I went to prison I had hit my bottom and
I entered recovery and um there are a
lot of people who are disappointed but
but a lot of people that I still feel
that I can serve in other ways what was
prison life for you wasn't easy I
wouldn't recommend it people say date
night one is is the worst because you
suddenly hear the clanking door and you
realize that's your life for the next
look it is it's a community like any
other so it has its challenges and so
some ways being someone in politics that
I was able to navigate those things I'm
someone who maybe because of issues that
I have had with my inner emotional state
that I was able to endure it either
easier than others but I wouldn't
recommend it I think it was it was it
was lucky for you you dodged
it did you have a good reception from
people in there or not so people look I
I I managed I I managed it the answer is
that I was a bit of a novelty until
you're not I mean there are lots of
people in prison who have lots who
everyone has a story and it's like
politics it's like being in any
Community you have people that are
difficult to deal with and you have
people that that show you a lot of
empathy and you have people that you you
know these are people in there for a
very long time I I got a great deal of
appreciation for the idea that we as a
Society you know throw people in prison
for long periods of time when probably
half the amount of time would probably
serve in sending the the message and a
lot of people are in there for things
like marijuana which are which are
barely even illegal nowadays so I
learned a lot about the system I think
that I at once had it harder and easier
than others and harder in that they
wanted to make it very clear that they
were not cutting me any a slack but I
also think they need they they made sure
that I didn't come home in a
box a lot of people say they get no
rehabilitation whatso ever from being
incarcerated I would imagine in your
case maybe not Rehabilitation but
re-evaluation of where you got to in
life and what you had to do when you
came out would that be fair well here I
found ways inside prison to be of
service to the other men there I found
ways to to take lessons and to learn
lessons and to and to to try to help
people who are struggling with things um
there wasn't anything good about it I
was away from my my son for for for 15
months and 8 Days um no there wasn't
anything good about it and I was already
well on my way to to to being a
healthier and better person long before
I went to prison I don't think I should
have gone to prison I take up full
responsibility for what got me there
though and um and so yeah I mean it
certainly isn't something I would say I
benefited from I I survived it when
you've looked back at it all can you
work out what what drove you to do that
to yourself I mean you basically blew up
your own career and life yeah when you
had so much going for you you were
married to a very beautiful successful
person who was working for Hillary
Clinton you know you had a young son
that who you loved career-wise you were
a highflying politician who knows how
far you could have gone and yet you you
blew it all up have you been able to
work out what did that you know but all
of those things maybe people not as
prominent as I all of those things are
things that people can say about the way
addiction the way mental issues affect
their lives there are a lot of people
who live great lives but who because of
inner demons because of challenges with
addiction it all gets blown up so
there's nothing unique about me except
that I did it in a very very public way
um it isn't immediately clear you know
what was the what was the the moment
zero that started it all but it seems if
pretty clear to me from everything I
understand that the way I was processing
things more and more input that I would
get more and more more and more
accolades more and more criticism more
and more feedback that I would get the
more that I craved and once technology
created a way that I can be getting it
Non-Stop and I could be interacting with
people non-stop in ways appropriate
inappropriate and everything in between
it it became something that that was
consuming to me and that and it became a
compulsive activity I understand that
now and understanding it's part of it
treating
it having a a rigorous program that kind
of keeps you on the straight narrow but
like so many people that deal with
mental issues they're not that far in
the background at any moment New York is
a City full of straight talkers
particularly in the street I've had it
good bad and ugly over the years when
you walk around how are New Yorkers with
you well New Yorkers and I think this is
true of everyone people are generally
nice to you in person I mean people are
generally very a athetic but for me I
was I'm a little bit of a Roy test for
people people sometimes come up to me
and embrace me on the street and say I
know what you've been through sometimes
people will come up to me and say I have
someone in my life that did something
like sometimes people would say up to do
you mind if I take your number and call
you because I'm dealing with something
similar sometimes people still stop me
in the street and say the the price of
steak is too high I can't believe you
don't you think Joe Biden is doing a
good job people I get all kinds of
things but overall it is all within not
all of it most it's within the the the
two goalposts of reasonable ways that
people deal with one another and I I
still enjoy it I can never imagine
living anywhere else your wife uh whom
abidin said of the scandals he didn't
just break my heart he ripped it out and
stomped on it over and over again that
must have been hard to hear very hard
she she actually said that in an amazing
book called
um also also I should know it but if if
and or something like that it's a great
book look this is again again the
experience you know when I go into rooms
of my 12-step program and I listen to
people talk about what they've put their
families through and how long it took
them to get in the right but but she
didn't deserve this she didn't bring
this on herself nor did my son nor did
my constituents nor did people like you
and the media who I lied to like just
out and out and lied to because I was in
such shame um but she I I I accept that
and and of of all of the people on the
list of amends that I need to make um
hers is one that I'm going to live the
rest of my life have you been
able to rebuild a good relationship with
hum OB you share a child very much so we
we we share a child we see each other
just about every day um she's one of my
biggest supporters hopefully I'm one of
her biggest supporters uh and uh look in
a way what we experienced is was so
generous there aren't people who can say
well what do you do if you're married to
a guy named weer who's in a sex scandal
and winds up going to prison when your
kid is is 8 years old and and um and I
also have an ex sense of what she went
through you know being being a person
who was connected with Hillary Clinton
who now she's on television herself and
to see her connected with some
outrageous you know islamophobia it's ra
outrageous story from qinon and all
these other things so um in in in a way
we're closer than we've ever been how
did you explain it all to your son he's
now at an age where he can read it all
if he wants to on the internet yeah well
so ever since he's been a young boy I
have tried to have conversations with
him in an age appropriate way there is
some adults in my life who don't
understand when I talk to them about
this stuff and so for him it is this is
trying to stay ahead of what he may find
out but being having this this notion of
honesty that his mom and I both say to
him um we can be a place that you can
come to for the truth about it and
there's a lot of crap that's out there
that's not true in addition to the stuff
that is true is a lot that's not true
and so I just try to talk up to him I
try to talk to him like he's older than
he is and just to be there for him when
he does decide to ask these questions
hopefully um I I I can do it in a way
that he value the honesty that I show
that I didn't show the world when I was
in the the depth of my troubles um and
also to kind of show him what what
coming out the other side of something
looks like what does it look
like I listen I you know there is a does
it still haunt you the whole thing or
you know I I I it doesn't because I have
come to
believe that these things happen for for
a reason that where I am right now you
know there's there's a great deal that
we do in life where we we we would feel
so much better if we just had a notion
of acceptance you know a lot of a lot of
Buddhists believe that the source of all
dis discontent is wanting things to be
different you know they there there's an
expression in my program abandon all
hope of a better past like this is where
I am I'm sitting here with you I'm
sitting someone I haven't seen over 10
years okay you're doing great I think
I'm doing okay I don't have this sense I
don't sit at home watching cpan three
throwing shoes at my TV that's not where
I am um and when someone invites me and
says I want to talk about it more often
than not I say yes because maybe somewh
out there in your audience is someone
who's going through crazy stuff that he
doesn't understand he thinks he's all
alone there's a community of people that
deal with these challenges the best
advice you got and who was it from about
how to deal with it all well you know
there are a lot of people it's it's it's
fascinating to me that a lot of the
people that were in my life as my quote
unquote supporters at the time were not
the ones that turned out that today are
the ones that I'm in touch with there
are some people that are but there are a
lot of people who are in the camp that I
said listen I consider myself his friend
the way I express my friendship as being
there for someone when they're in a
tough time
politicians generally don't think that
way they Chuck you under a bus right nor
do media people to be honest and and the
reason is could be varied but but the
the the people that have given me the
best advice are not the people that said
all right you should do this interview
or don't do that interview it's people
that that reach out to me and says
listen I'm on a program that sounds like
you could use come on down you'll be
among people that care about you uman I
mean did you ever hear from Hillary
Clinton or Bill Clinton I mean Bill
Clinton himself went through tremendous
sex scandals humiliating his wife did
you ever hear from them yeah so remember
there are different arcs after I left
Congress in 2011 shortly after you and I
did our last interview um it was a it
was a sexting Scandal that was a sexting
Scandal it seemed kind of weird at the
time I was the first Twitter sexting
Scandal right um and then when I tried
to make a comeback in
2013 I had not fully put down those
activities I had periodically I never
treated it the way I should have treated
it as a real mental elter I treated as
something that wasn't that important to
really deal with and so then it became a
situation where it got harder for people
who gave me that second chance to say
I'm going to give you a third chance but
I don't that's not on them that's on me
I was the one that betrayed these
relationships I was the one that did
these things and I have to clean up
that's why an important part of of of
continuing with life is to make amends
to all of those people that I put in a
very difficult position you've been a
very skillful politician in that answer
by I'm probably the best natural
politician you've ever interview yes
yeah you were one of the well you were
certainly one of the most
bombastic uh on the front foot
uncompromising and smart politicians
I've interviewed no question it's nice
of you to say no question that's why
what follow was for you a great tragedy
right there's no question but you didn't
answer about the clintons is there a
reason you don't want to say other way
no it's because it's hard to Market when
my first Scandal happened and this first
thing became and then people did kind of
to some degree rally around me it seemed
kind of a weird thing I mean for I had
sent pictures to I sent a picture on
someone on Twitter who I meant it not to
be and it wasn't my my fiance at the
time or my wife at the time it was a
weird thing but I wanted to get out from
under I saw your interview with George
Santos I was not interested in I I I
knew that I was going to be a
distraction problematic so I I resigned
later on when these things reemerged and
people had given me a secondary then
there was much less of an effort to
reach out and to be honest with you I
didn't I didn't want to further in bring
anyone else into it so the the the
clintons have have been very supportive
to me up until the point that I probably
didn't deserve their
support of course it had catastrophic
impact on you personally but it had a
pretty catastrophic professional impact
not just for you but for a lot of other
people because as part of the criminal
investigation into the final sexting
scandal with what turned out to be a
girl of 15 as part of that They seized
your laptop and on the laptop they found
the infamous emails which led to James
Comey at the FBI opening up again the
case into Hillary Clinton which many
people including her believe tip the
election Donald Trump's way so that the
consequences of your behavior had a
quite spectacular impact on America and
on that presidential race
do you think looking at it
dispassionately now years later do you
think that without that investigation
into you your laptop and the discovery
of those emails and the reopening of
that investigation Hillary would have
been
president look it's very easy to do
these the butterflies wings flapped and
all these different things happened now
that we know that the the Russians were
putting their their finger and their
money very heavily down on on the on on
the scale and that it was it was it was
likely the Russians that hacked into
podesta emails and turned them over to
WikiLeaks and these things like that to
say that any one particular thing led to
it now there's no doubt that James Comey
probably contributed to to to as close
as it was to um Donald Trump being
president now can you say if it was not
me that James Comey did something
corrupt with my laptop would it not have
been something else could it been
something else that the Russians did as
but it was your laptop ultimately it it
was my laptop but you say did I think it
was it was conclusive in the race it
could be it's a race as close as it was
you can point to the amount of times
that Hillary didn't go to Wisconsin
because you didn't think it was
understand you can point to the other
ways that the Russian I just wonder
whether you feel any sense of guilt the
answer is the answer is I do but I also
don't believe being knowing this
business I'm not sure I buy the point A
to point B analysis but if people want
to hold that view I certainly respect it
you know generally speaking things don't
change that much close to the election
but I can tell you that the trauma that
it's caused me and my wife because of
that of of that perception I I get it
I'm I'm not going to dispute him when
something is as close as it is something
like 60,000 votes in three states are
the difference if you want to point to
something that that changed the dynamic
I'm I'm I'm willing to cop to that did
you apologize to Hillary
personally I did not apolog I don't
recall if I AP apologized personally but
I
don't I don't I might have I might have
dropped her note as part of my amends
process saying I'm sorry for any any
harm that I mean he remember surely no I
I did I did letters and the like as part
of my eight step as part of my making
amends remember if You' written to
Hillary saying I'm sorry about what
happened no I I if you're asking me am I
sorry about what happened certainly I
did no no but I'm asking did you
actually write that letter do you think
yes but you I thought you asking with
the laptop are you asking generally did
generally any impact I had on her I I
with terrible distraction that it was
you actually wrote her a letter saying
that I yeah as I I did did she
reply
um that's between
us I mean it's extraordinary as we sit
here talking about the next election and
we actually we're not talking about the
next election we're talking about two
elections well no no we began by talking
about the next one and it's obviously
started this week it's just fascinating
to me to be with somebody who's been
through been through the ringer no
question um but also may have played a
part in history you know albeit that
wasn't why you were doing what you were
doing and you never thought through that
that could be a consequence but you know
you are a part of American presidential
history in that sense that's a heavy
toll to Bear never mind everything else
if if you want to if you want to
construct it that way I wonder I wonder
if you do you're I I I I don't I mean
you've you've given this more thought
perhaps than than than I have I mean I I
view it that look A Thing Happened a a a
someone with responsibility not to do
corrupt things did a corrupt thing and
help swing the election to Donald Trump
I'm not contesting that if it were not
me would it have been something else
were there not another list of things
that it could be all I can say is I
generally speaking am not someone who's
going back and Naval gazing about that
as it turned out Hillary Clinton beat
him by six million votes five and a half
million votes as it as it turned out
there were tactical decisions that were
made as it turned out there were two of
the most unpopular candidates in
American history did Anthony Weiner's
laptop make one of them more popular or
less popular I'm not sure I'm buying it
I'm much more persuasive is what is what
Donald Trump's intelligence um agency
said which is it was part of Russia's
systematic effort to steal the election
for him so was I part of that could be
so was John podesta I mean John
podesta's emails arguably had a much
greater impact on that campaign than I
did did you ever hear from Donald
Trump about any of this
anything no no no you've had no contact
with him no I mean he's been he's been
baffo for my ratings on the radio but no
he hasn't uh he has hasn't reached out
what do you make of the Trump phenomenon
which it clearly is I mean he not only
won as the least qualified candidate in
history against the most qualified which
was spectacular enough but he now looks
like he's a got a very good chance of
being Republican nominee or be you don't
think he'll beat Biden but the the Trump
phenomenon is an extraordinary thing
politically well Trump is an
extraordinary thing and the effect that
he's had on on disemboweling the
Republican party has been fascinating to
watch I mean just about everything that
I knew about the Republican Party
growing up is now not true they're now
the party of Putin they're now the party
that that basically refuses they There's
No Business wing of that party that
talks about immigration and responsible
way and things like that um for those of
us who are New Yorkers like we've known
Donald Trump a very long time
and we know he's a jackass and we know
he's not good at business and we know he
doesn't have as much money as he said
and we know that he's generally a
buffoon now the fact that he has
successfully thanks to his TV stuff been
marketed as something to the American
people that about a third of them which
is really all it is about a third of
them think that he's a good president
should continue to do that um and was
good that's 100 million people a third
of America well not a third when that's
not no he basically what did he get in
the last election 75 million 72 I think
but that you got 10 million more voted
for him after four years of trump
presidency than the first time he also
lost not he also lost by a much bigger
margin and the guy's never carried the
my point being though it's not it's not
a small number of people it is it's a
relatively small percentage all I said
is about a third of the country I mean
he's not he's not very popular and we do
have a system in this country that many
of your viewers would find bizarre that
we have an an inherent uh the the the
the electoral college system inherently
benefits the minority party in this case
which is the Republicans so and and he
was a lousy president was tossed out in
his ass so in in a way that is par for
the course here in New York like we know
him as that guy and now we've had trials
that have shown that he he clearly knew
that he was full of it at the time and
that he was so struggling in 2014 and 15
that if he didn't get lower interest
rate loans then he would he would be be
out of it and now he's he's he's
struggling here the reason he's spending
so much time in New York is he know is
if he's got one remaining building
that's worth anything and he may lose
that so we are kind of amused by the
whole thing as a Democrat he's been a
boon to our country in is that he's
completely crushed the Republican party
they can't win anything since he's been
in office including his his own races
and now you've you you know you you've
got an an an animated country to to to
to make sure he doesn't become and he
could wind up in prison so that's about
powerful the way we How would how would
he Faire if he winds up in prison you
know you've been there I don't I I don't
I I I I can't even imagine what it's
like could could he handle it do you
think it's
look I'm I'm sure if they did a if they
made sure that Anthony Weiner came home
in one piece I'm sure they'll make sure
that he comes comes comes home in one
would it be good for America if he is
convicted of any one of the 91 charges
would it be good for America to see any
president go to prison or would it be
better for him to be pardoned I I I
generally think well I don't about
pardon in that eventuality no I I don't
if pardoning is necessary I do believe
that this has been an important Civic
moment for the United States of America
to test this theory that no one is above
the law I happen to think that this is a
kind of a good moment for our system if
it holds it h it's held up to now um
whether he actually wears a prison
jumpsuit and goes into the hole while
he's being tested for TB and all these
other things I don't even think that
that's the most important thing to be
honest with you but the notion that he
stands accountable is a very American
ideal and um I I think we should see it
through but as far as him being in
prison it's not the most important thing
Joe Biden when asked about you said oh
God Anthony weer I shouldn't comment on
Anthony Weiner I'm not a big fan I
wasn't before he got into trouble so I
shouldn't comment on Anthony Weiner yeah
I actually use that in the bumper for my
radio show you haven't even mentioned
it's called The Middle on WABC radio the
the the middle you can get as a podcast
all around the world um I have that
bumper and one from from Donald Trump
saying something on the stump about me
yeah I'm not a big fan of Joe Biden when
I was in in Congress I think he's done a
pretty good job as president but I I I'm
not sure when he if he and I saw each
other we'd give each other a big hug do
you feel that what he's been through
with his son Hunter is kind of ironic
given his dislike of you I don't see the
connection just that maybe he's realized
that life can oh oh be difficult no no
no that was was a comment when he was
vice president I was at once very
helpful to his administration with Obama
on Obamacare and other things but very
critical for the way that they very
often were not very good politicians and
so I had had a tetto with him when he
came before the Democratic caucus where
I called him out for for being not
idiots politically and he hasn't likeed
me ever since but but but I don't know
if the hunter Biden has any connection
to it if Donald Trump can make a
comeback and potentially even win the
White House again why can't you I mean
many would say a lot of the stuff he's
got up over the years makes you look
like a Cho boy I I don't I don't I don't
know I I I there's plenty of good people
you know there's some some of it's
generational I mean I started old I'm 59
59 I mean by political standards by Joe
B no no I I don't I'm not I'm
not I'm not over the hill but in terms
of there there but are you over politics
here's what such a political animal you
always were I I I do I do on a conser
the most conservative radio station in
New York I'm the one liberal guy I'm the
guy doing classical music on a hip-hop
station um and I get to scratch the itch
that way I get to go back and forth with
callers I get to go back and forth with
guests I get plenty of chances to kind
of scratch the itch of being of service
to my community I I'm kind of now kind
of an elder Statesman politicians call
me for advice and things like that but
do I really want to go and rehash all of
these things again do I really want to
do I want to ask for a third chance I am
a a good politician I would have been an
excellent mayor I would have been better
than Deasia I would have been better
than Eric Adams but all of that being
said is that politics is like a lot of
things in life it's about being at the
right place at the right time being what
the people are looking for at that
particular moment being a good candidate
and I think that I I can reasonably have
people say to me listen we gave you that
chance a couple of times you blew it um
you had your chance but I'm I'm enjoying
what I'm doing now did any of the
celebrities who sucked up to you when
they thought you might be mayor or they
thought Hillary might win and your wife
would therefore be working at the White
House all those celebrities who would
have been all over you like a rash any
any of them stand by you after it all
went down well I dated Lady Gaga for a
while that didn't go very well I'm just
kidding I look
I you know what I mean I mean I no I I
totally do but let me just say I I think
there is this
notion that politicians are all
self-interested they they're not there
are some very good people and there are
some people like my former roommate in
Congress he and I stay in touch and and
the like but asking people to be
supportive of me is to some degree
asking them to risk getting in trouble
like you know sometimes I'll have a
politician friend of mine reach out to
me and say would can you make a donation
in my campaign or can you come and and
meet with my staff and give them advice
on field and like think about that
minute do you really want that headline
Anthony Weiner is helping our campaign
and so if politicians are a very
different type Mo most of the people who
rallied around me the hardest were the
regular type of person who I'm like I
know that guy he's kind of I know him
okay that person said he that person who
treated me as as like a a test of his
friendship or her friendship those are
the people that are in my life to this
day for whom I'm very grateful but I
don't hold it against I mean I know
you're trying to get to this like did
these politicians do they sell you out
no I I did these things actually I meant
actually celebrities in particular
famous people you know who entertainers
who like to hang around politicians I
think are on the particularly the
liberal fast there there are some there
are some to which I've gotten closer
because they're in recovery too do
that's fascinating any you could you
could name the whole idea like a lot of
our a lot of the programs that I'm
involved in are Anonymous programs but
the answer is no but there are people
have an idea of like you and Charlie
Sheen hanging out having a there there
are a lot of there there are a lot of
people a lot of people in your business
too to be honest are are in these rooms
I mean these things that have that we're
we're reflecting back on ourselves we're
being judged based on clicks and ratings
and everything else um it does it does
put people and actors are like that too
who kind of like are putting themselves
out there and and everything else and it
sometimes it turns out that's a
reflection of needing something you know
they could talk about a a god-shaped
hole that you're like have something
that's missing so some of those people
have but but I I have absolutely no
qualms at the way the world has
responded to me that I am not in any way
a victim here I have victimized other
people and I need to make amends to
those people but I believe that part of
why I'm here and part of this and part
of the reason I said gladly yes to come
on and chat with you is because I
believe that part of the way I can be of
service in the years to come is not
necessarily voting on stuff in
Washington or giving a heated speech
but maybe having someone see what I've
been through and say you know what okay
that guy's named Weiner and he's having
a sex scandal and went to prison and
lost his career if if if he can come out
the other side then I can too have you
been tempted finally at any stage of all
this to change your name no why would
you can't you can't do it legally is
Pierce Morgan your actual name I
wondered that yes is it really it's a
very TV name uh I know I can't imagine
it and people say the same thing would
you ever leave New York you know like
move to Iowa for example me it's part of
don't you believe that if you wanted to
conceive of a of like how would I have
my undoing it would be in this way how
would I finally be laid low someone like
me it would have to be all of this it
would have to be named weer it have to
be a postmodern sex scandal that with
people I've never met never made any
effort to meet um the answer is no I'm
I'm I'm I'm very and by the way the last
original insult I heard about my name I
heard in the fifth grade so it's like
not I'm not hear anything new now
Anthony winner it's good to catch up you
as well could come back to New York
anytime I can't give you key to the city
but I can make you welcome good to see
you you as well all the
best